walls trees cars homes little stands in
the path of a tornado this chain of
twisters began on Monday some gusted at
140 miles an hour in the state of Ohio
the wind gutted an entire block of flats
I was screaming lord help me Lord help
me and they I heard him say sue we're
comin so far more than a hundred and
thirty people have been injured and one
man died when a car whipped up by the
wind crashed into his home a weather
warning is in place across the United
States from New York State down through
the Midwest and as far west as Idaho
Indiana has been hit by 14 tornadoes so
far
Ohio's had 11 with more forecast until
the end of this week we don't have any
magic wand as far as me coming in here
and and I can't put these houses back
together we have some understanding of
what you're going through we're gonna do
absolutely anything that we can that you
want us to do that we can do to be of
help in amongst the carnage have been
stories of incredible courage in
Oklahoma City
Preston Black lifted his trailer to
rescue his wife who was trapped
underneath all the things that were
smashing her I pushed it up with my both
hands like a [ __ ] press I pushed it all
up some states have declared major
emergencies helping them to quickly
access money to start the cleanup and
help those who've lost so much katarina
vote Otzi's Sky News